nous sommes le 14 mars 2020 je suis à la
pharmacie journée anodine
j'ai une patiente du troisième âge qui
viennent nous voir avec sa prescription
des médicaments et vous le savez en tant
que pharmacien
je rassure mes patients je leur apporte
des solutions aux différents problèmes
liés à leur thérapie et je suis souvent
l'un des professionnels de la santé en
qui ils ont le plus confiance
ce jour là la patiente vient donc nous
voir pour renouveler ces médicaments est
également profité pour faire la jasette
vous savez certains de nos patients à
prendre le temps à la pharmacie je
regarde sa prescription prescription de
renouvellement visuel et pendant que je
rentre la prescription dans le système
elle voit une expression dubitative sur
mon visage et m'interpelle
monsieur le pharmacien est ce que ça va
je lui réponds oui ça va mais à
l'intérieur de moi j'ai un doute
est ce que cette fois ci je serai en
mesure de lui servir son médicament
comme je le fais d'habitude
chaque mois je prends le temps de voir
si j'ai une solution immédiate mais je
n'en ai pas elle me demande encore
monsieur le pharmacien est ce que ça va
je lui dit écoutez madame comme
d'habitude je vais prendre soin de vous
vous devriez avoir encore quelques jours
de médicaments à la maison
d'après mon système alors permettez moi
de trouver une solution pour renouveler
vos médicaments et je vous contacte très
rapidement elle mettait d'accord je vous
fais confiance
et là je dois vous avouer la confiance
n'était pas entièrement la gta animé par
en doute car le médicaments usuels de ma
patiente n'était pas disponible
mon nom est kevin mais jo et je suis
pharmacien alors dans les prochaines
minutes je vous invite à rentrer
dans la tête d'un pharmacien d'ici qui
fait face à ce type de problème lorsque
certaines personnes voient un médicament
il voit une bouteille une boîte un
flacon
lorsque je regarde des médicaments je
vois ceux qui à l'intérieur du
médicament c'est qu'il contient c'est
qui le composent soient principalement
deux choses un ingrédient actif qui fait
effet sur la cible thérapeutique à
l'intérieur du corps et des ingrédients
non actifs comme par exemple la
méthylcellulose qui est incorporé dans
la matrice du comprimé pour former la
masse du comprimé et contrôler la
libération de l'ingrédient actif
donc si le médicament n'est pas
disponible c'est qu'il ya un problème
lié à la disponibilité de l'ingrédient
actif ou à la disponibilité des
ingrédients non actifs bien évidemment
vous comprenez je simplifie pour fins
d'illustration et là on rentre dans le
vif du sujet
c'est là que ça devient intéressant
quels événements peuvent avoir une
influence sur la disponibilité des
ingrédients de nos médicaments
bonne question est importante question
premier élément de réponse assez évident
mais que peu auraient pu prévoir la
cofidis 9
malheureusement nous sommes encore en
plein dedans et j'adresse toutes mes
sympathies aux personnes affectées par
cette pandémie
on a beaucoup parlé de roanne au début
de la pandémie
c'était le premier épicentre que l'on a
découvert et dont la presse a beaucoup
ciblées mais ce que l'on sait moins
c'est que roanne est la capitale de la
province du tibet et que le hub et
possède un des plus grand nombre
d'installations de fabrication
d'ingrédients actifs au monde même
continent autres pays problèmes
similaires
quand j'ouvre le journal ces jours ci je
lis que l'inde est à son tour en proie à
une recrudescence
alarmant rica et devinez quoi
l'inde est un autre des ces pays sur
lesquels on compte beaucoup pour la
fabrication des médicaments
deuxième événement improbable il ya de
cela quelques semaines elle a mis dans
un esprit très blagueur m'envoie le
fameux mime je transportais en bloquant
le canal de suez
si l'instant j'ai souri mais mon sourire
était très éphémère car le canal de suez
représente 10 % du transport maritime
mondial je me suis demandé quand est il
si su ce transporteur se trouve le
médicament de ma patiente
lorsqu'on regarde un peu plus loin on se
rend compte qu'au pic de la pandémie
actuelle nous avons eu une diminution
des vols commerciaux est aussi une
diminution de la capacité de fret aérien
et de fret maritime ce qui résulte en
une réduction de la disponibilité et une
augmentation du coût de transport
ce que je veux dire ici et que nous ne
vivons plus en silo les problèmes
globaux qui arrive ailleurs que ce soit
en chine en inde ou tout autre endroit
du monde où un impact potentiel sur
notre accessibilité aux médicaments et
nous devons donc y réfléchir
autres événements non prévus
plus proche de nous ici à montréal a été
la grève au port de montréal
une fois de plus qu'en est il si le
médicament de ma patiente s'y trouvent
en attente d'être dédouanés face à ce
type d'événements sans précédent et non
prévus regardons comment est ce que les
différents acteurs de l'industrie ont
réagi au canada pour éviter des
conséquences graves
avant même qu'il y ait une pénurie les
autorités réglementaires
santé canada ont rapidement à j santé
canada a adopté un arrêté d'urgence
visant à permettre l'importation et la
vente de médicaments essentiels un
risque de pénurie en pandémie de kobe 19
en temps normal avant que médicament ne
soit commercialisé au canada
il doit être éthique été selon nos
exigences notamment en matière de langue
est passé à travers le processus
d'homologation de santé canada en temps
de pandémie
les autorités ont créé une voie rapide
est permis de manière exceptionnelle
d'importer des médicaments homologués
étiquetés et commercialisé dans l'union
européenne qui partagent des similarités
en termes d'exigences réglementaires
le travail a été fait de concert avec
les compagnies pharmaceutiques d'ici
afin d'importer ces médicaments souvent
utilisés dans nos hôpitaux et donc nous
avions anticipé une hausse de la demande
durant la pandémie de kobe 19 on pense
notamment au salbutamol la pompe qui est
utilisé pour l'asthme et difficultés
respiratoires ou la morphine qui est
utilisé pour le traitement de la douleur
d'autre part les fabricants de
médicaments ont rapidement agi pour
répondre à des risques anticipé de
pénurie locale de médicaments essentiels
pour ce faire ils ont protégé les
niveaux d'inventaires de médicaments et
travailler de concert avec les
grossistes pour assurer un
approvisionnement adéquat des
médicaments quand ceux ci ne pouvaient
être faits localement
l'industrie a fait appel à son réseau de
partenaires à l'extérieur du canada
aussi rendre disponibles les médicaments
aux chercheurs pour les études cliniques
afin d'évaluer leur utilisation dans le
traitement du couvent et 19 à cet effet
montréal a accueilli l'une des plus
grandes études cliniques permettant du
mieux analyser une des cibles
thérapeutiques dans le traitement du coc
u19 il y a de quoi être fier également
les professionnels de la santé dont les
pharmaciens les médecins les infirmiers
infirmières et tous les autres
d'ailleurs ont dû s'employer a
rapidement développé des mesures et des
protocoles pour s'assurer qu'on utilise
de manière optimale les stocks
disponibles
ceci afin que l' on priorise d'abord les
patients qui étaient dans les besoins
les plus urgents les acteurs de
l'industrie pharmaceutique et du réseau
de la santé
comme vous avez pu le voir ont pris les
choses en main si nous restons dans le
thème de la vision qui nous unissent
aujourd'hui et qu'on regarde vers le
futur
quels sont les enjeux dont il faudra
tenir compte
face au prochain événement improbable d
ordre naturel nouvelles pandémies ou
crise mondiale le premier de ces enjeux
et l'empreinte écologique de la
fabrication des ingrédients actifs dans
les dernières années nous observons une
augmentation du besoin en ingrédients
actifs pour faire nos médicaments
ces besoins sont accrus lorsque des
événements non prévus arrive et qu'il
faut rapidement pouvoir répondre à la
demande
toutefois nous devons repenser la
production des ingrédients des
médicaments en tenant compte de
l'empreinte écologique de la fabrication
j'illustre mon propos avec ceux ci un
produit comme l'ibuprofène chez l'humain
a un effet bénéfique sur la douleur et
l'inflammation
toutefois l'exposition prolongée à de
faibles quantités conduit à une
modification d'activité de certaines
espèces de la faune aquatique
pensons-y deuxième enjeu celui de
l'innovation
cette pandémie nous a rappelé
l'importance de l'innovation dans le
secteur des sciences et de la vie de nos
jours on peut développer des vaccins de
manière encore plus rapide en maintenant
une collaboration entre les chercheurs
d'ici et de là bas
les résultats de l'innovation ne sont
pas toujours immédiat toutefois en
matière de traitements et vaccins contre
la kfw 19 c'est une des solutions
incontournables pour redémarrer le monde
et retrouver un sentiment de normalité
dans nos vies il faudra donc maintenir
un financement constant et adéquat dans
ses initiatives afin de renforcer la
chaîne d'innovation
le troisième enjeu et l'efficience de la
chaîne d'approvisionnement
comme on le constate il y a plusieurs
intermédiaires entre la fabrication de
l'ingrédient actif qui forment le
produit jusqu aux mains du patient
l'intégration de l'intelligence
artificielle et l'apprentissage
automatique comme on dit en anglais
machine learning combiné au big data et
à l'analyse prédictive ont le potentiel
d'améliorer les opérations et les
performances au long de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement
l'intelligence artificielle et le
machine learning ont également le
potentiel d'aider les différents
intervenants à identifier des parker et
tendance jusque là inconnu créant ainsi
des opportunités significatives pour le
développement de solutions véritablement
innovantes
on peut ainsi prendre exemple sur
d'autres secteurs qui ont une avance
dans l'intégration de ces technologies
le quatrième enjeu est celui de la
capacité de production les meilleurs
modèles prédictifs ne peuvent pas
participer une pandémie
un autre engin a considéré et notre
modèle de tarification des médicaments
le prix des médicaments génériques a
diminué de 60% en le disant
je reprends le prix des médicaments
génériques
diminué de 60 % en dix ans au canada les
différents paliers de gouvernement ont
tourné la vis sur le taux de
remboursement des médicaments et la
logique on la comprend
diminuer la facture globale des
médicaments cependant à l'ère où les
fabricants de médicaments doivent
investir davantage pour solidifier la
chaîne d'approvisionnement il faut
assurer des niveaux de prix durables
pour les médicaments afin de permettre
qu'ils soient économiquement possible de
produire des médicaments au canada et
d'être suffisamment compétitif pour
acquérir des produits finis et autres
intrants sur le marché international
également inspiré les entrepreneurs qui
participent activement à s'assurer qu'on
ait des médicaments de qualité et ainsi
réussi la capacité manufacturière et
l'autonomie pharmaceutique ici au québec
et au canada
comme vous le constatez derrière le
médicament se trouve un éventail des
défis qui préoccupe le pharmacien que je
suis nous devons continuer cette
réflexion pour briser les silos et crié
des circonstances favorables afin de
renforcer la chaîne d'approvisionnement
et la chaîne d'innovation des
médicaments je vous ramène maintenant
auprès de ma patiente
lorsqu'elle est revenue à la pharmacie
je lui étais indiqué madame j'ai pu
trouver une solution autre médicament
est maintenant disponible
toutefois je dois vous avouer que si
vous et moi ainsi que tous les acteurs
concernés
poussons à voir les fruits de cette
réflexion dont nous engageons
aujourd'hui alors à la prochaine
pandémie ou au prochain événement
improbable
le pharmacien serait davantage confiant
à trouver une solution pour ces patients
je vous remercie pour votre attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]